we've been at this war for forty years
we've spent a trillion dollars on
much-needed dollars in other ways we've
had forty five million drug arrests what
do we have to show for America's public
enemy number one is drug abuse
what are you doing someone offers you
drugs hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV
and I'm joined today by the acclaimed
documentary filmmaker Eugene Jarecki who
is behind the brand-new the house I live
in a great drug war documentary that is
just come out nationwide or is coming
out nationwide thank you very much for
joining us today so you've done
documentaries on the military industrial
complex on Henry Kissinger on Ronald
Reagan why did you choose to do the drug
war as a documentary it's a matter of
justice and a matter of common sense
public policy we have a tragically
misguided approach to drugs in this
country as people across a spectrum I
think deep down know I went to 25 states
to talk to people at all levels in law
enforcement and corrections jailers
wardens cops judges senators I almost
couldn't find to a person someone who
would defend the horrendous track record
and contemporary workings of the drug
war so suddenly I found on my hands I
like to make very measured balanced
movies that explore something and let us
all be the judge but when you hear from
a judge that the drug war has tied his
hands when cops tell you from the front
seat of their patrol car that they
arrest the same people day in day out
week after week without any progress for
the community when you hear from
corrections that the system just keeps
making more and more bodies that fill
their facilities the tragedy is so
widespread and it's so felt by the
people within it that it made it very
hard to get out on the road and make the
sort of measured film that I typically
like to make this is a film that says
this is an American crisis on that note
let's look at the film a clip of Mike
carpenter in Oklahoma prison guard
I have very much a law-and-order kind of
guy I would rather have ten police cars
than one soup kitchen if you give me the
choice but sometimes I think that we
need to be smarter about what those
police officers are actually out there
doing maybe because he seemed the
epitome of a hardened prison official my
carpenters perspective on the severity
of drug laws caught me off guard I think
a long time ago we made drugs into this
huge thing and we've made it so illegal
and we've made it such a national issue
with that tough on crime stance I mean
you can't get elected if you don't
profess to be tough on crime first we
have to join together to ensure that
drug dealers are punished swiftly surely
and severely he can't stay elected if
you don't do things to be tough on crime
is to toughen sentences beefed up law
enforcement and build new prison space
for 24,000 inmates you know nobody can
afford to be the first guy to say wait a
minute we can't afford what we're doing
let's do something different because if
you even made a noise like you were
going to be soft on crime in any way you
wouldn't be out of a job you will be put
away and put away for good three strikes
and you are out
was he character and were there other
characters who you thought going in I I
finally got a drug warrior yes and then
they surprised you and turned out not to
be perfect question when I first saw
Mike from a hundred yards this guy is
the he is the picture book imagining I
had of a tough-on-crime knuckle-dragging
lock him up and throw away the key con a
guy so remember sitting down with him
thinking I finally have my bad guy and
within five minutes you discover he
doesn't agree with the system he's got
not only does he have deep reservations
about it he's incredibly eloquent with
those reservations in a way few people
can be the movie it talks about
political and structural things but it's
not a headline political movie it's not
about it's certainly not about Barack
Obama he shows up a little bit at the
end I think in that big it was kind of
way why did you choose I mean we're this
is coming out a month before the
election we have legalization on the
ballots in three states Obama has had a
very mixed
occurred as a as a drug warrior in some
ways worse than george w bush why did
you choose not to use the word
legalization in the movie and talk about
kind of headline politics because I tend
not to make films that are designed to
attack people I don't think that I think
that's a political distraction I
actually think it's politically impotent
if you want long-term change with a long
vision you have to make a film with a
long vision and to be preoccupied with
one politician or another in the present
when you're really looking at something
that's been with us for decades
you're gonna confuse the public into
thinking they can vote this way a little
sorry its those Democrats or those
Republicans who are the evildoers or
whatever else it's the whole system at
this point this is an evil that's been
mixed in with our drinking water we
bought into this in a wholesale way so
that we have become the world's largest
jailer with 2.3 million people behind
bars we've been at this war for 40 years
we've spent a trillion dollars on it
much-needed dollars in other ways we've
had forty five million drug arrests what
do we have to show for it
drugs are purer more available cheaper
today and more in use by younger and
younger people than ever before it's a
failure on every level and so the good
news is that's an opportunity it's an
opportunity finally to say enough is
enough and to get people across the
spectrum whether it's Brad Pitt Grover
Norquist
jay-z and on and on you have a brand new
constituency even Pat Robertson spoke
out against the drug war one of the
strongest kind of takeaways from the
movie comes from the analysis that a lot
of the history of drug prohibition is
inextricably linked to the history of
racial hatred or fear intolerance on
that topic let's cut to another clip
from the film while following the steps
that so many Americans take through the
world of the drug war I couldn't help
but notice that at every stage black
Americans were disproportionately
represented you know in any war you've
got to have an enemy
and when you think about the impact
particularly on poor people of color
there are more african-americans under
correctional control today in prison or
jail on probation or parole than were
enslaved in 1850 a decade before the
Civil War began and that's something we
haven't been willing to look in the
mirror and ask ourselves what's really
going on was this a surprise is this one
of the bigger surprises that you
encountered and making it is that one of
the things he served learned in the
process sure I mean growing up after the
civil rights movement in America in the
1970s I had a lot of friendships in the
black community for a lot of reasons
having to do with how Jews like my
family fled Europe and came to America
and sort of saw in the black struggle a
sister struggle - the struggle of Jews
in Europe I understood growing up that
there was a racial issue and it
increasingly took sort of root in my
perception of the drug war the idea that
we had had racist drug laws before that
was brand-new when I started to make the
film and came into contact with experts
on the subject who said you know I mean
the first drug laws we had were in the
1800s against Chinese people where we
had opium laws they were really just
thinly veiled laws about racial control
to keep the Chinese immigrant population
in California in check and these laws
have always been kind of random and
selective you know the number one user
of opium at that time in America was a
middle-aged white woman all across the
country largely in the south and yet we
didn't make opium illegal across the
country we only made it illegal in
California and we didn't even make
taking opium illegal in California we
only made smoking opium illegal in
California how convenient that that was
the way the Chinese used it they smoked
it so we made smoking opium illegal in
California specifically where they were
immigrating - how does the drug war end
I think the drug war ends in this
country and I am optimistic about it
because the public voice rises and Rises
until it until it really outweighs the
ever more Hollow rhetoric coming out of
the political class in the corporate
class who are really just clinging to
this thing because it's profitable to
themselves but it's not in the interest
of the public it's not good for America
it's weakening us it compromises us in
the eyes of the world
it erodes our labor force it damages our
inner cities it compromises Public
Safety because police are focused on the
wrong things it we waste tens of
billions a year that we can't afford and
so I think it changes because common
sense prevails through the voice of the
of the public and makes it increasingly
uncomfortable for politicians to play
the same old tough-on-crime games that
they've played for decades
Eugene Jarecki thank you very much the
movie is the house I live in for reason
TV I am Matt Welch